where we dropping nuts you guys want to
hit up till it's ours
yeah let's do this
mock mean you're gonna go to the castles
oh you guys you guys say the l-shaped
buttons all right ten-four Roger Roger
Go Go Go boys victory royale is incoming
it's ours derrida tomorrow train boys
just wait a second have you actually
taken a minute you just look around the
views are spectacular Wow it makes me
want to sing love songs Oh what what are
you talking about like God who gives a
[ __ ] we gotta get down here start the
thick is he do is is he singing okay
guys legitimate question who the [ __ ]
invited him to play with us alright
let's check out we can three man tempted
no problem you boys bringing this w
let's bring the fire
knocked one follow my gut just up
destroyed
[ __ ] back to the lobby beautiful you
got yeah oh come on first yeah
everywhere all right you guys please
left I got right I got one of me no I
said all right here's last one I think
that's the last one we shoved in
register
I'm like again bro we should dude that
was [ __ ] awesome how many kills did
you guys get
I got 11 baby let's get it 9 for me
let's I'm having a game of my life boys
13 kills all right the safe songs over
tomorrow as soon as we got the building
the base boys got it dude ten-four only
one person left there's four of us
this will be our victory victory
business still alive lady boys I am here
to guide you to victory well it's about
time [ __ ]
Sean how did dogs work how's my cat
inside the structure wait wait wait are
you seriously asking how to get in this
building Hey can't do it the gate the
gangs broke dude it's not broken you're
broken that's right you're broken it
must be a glitch don't worry guys I'll
use my pickaxe instead wait no no no no
no my bad sorry guys
you still around guys hello hello rest
of my team Sean why the did you invite
this guy Zach I can't I can't stand him
dude I hate you dude oh that's a bit
harsh everyone Shh
the last guy is north look concentrate
Adam you can do this oh don't you worry
lads I have got this covered are you
waiting for chute guys I've just had the
greatest idea ever
we need a
360noscope don't you dare it's already
happening boys get on board let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god you [ __ ] idiot
ah so close next time Jen's next time I
will land that shot there will never be
a next time I might just go play a few
solos
okay I'm out I'm out guys yep guys guys
guys
hello is anybody anybody still there
anyone yeah they must have they must
have locked down yeah they definitely
like them
[Music]
better who smashed it
oh I should be a singer how awesome am I